olá olá
e vamos comigo fazer uma viagem para
perceber um futuro positivo bora
com muito prazer eu sou o Tiago Lopes eu
mostro o mundo de forma positiva eu sou
influenciador passo videos de viagens
Life Style também sou apresentador
mestre de cerimônias palestrante só
alegria mas eu nem sempre fui essa
pessoa assim otimista é tem um momento
que eu tive uma virada de chave isso
aconteceu quando eu tava numa situação
muito triste quem já passou por um
momento difícil na vida já sentiu isso e
sabe o que eu tô falando eu já tinha
conversado o canal ainda não sabe o rumo
que ele teria Eu não queria fazer
conteúdo falando mal reclamando das
coisas eu queria criar conteúdo com bons
olhos aí eu ganhei um convite para ir
para o maior festival de música
eletrônica do mundo que tava tendo
medição no Brasil eu já conheci esse
festival
é só que eu não tava na vibe de ir mas
eu ganhei o convite era de graça eu
falei então vamos né fui lá gravar o
vídeo um dia antes do festival acabar eu
já tinha ido embora para casa dos meus
pais aí meninas porque família é tudo né
Ainda mais quando a gente não tá bem aí
eu fiquei lá editando vídeo e meu pai
ficou volta e meia percebendo alguma
coisa perguntando eu observei essa
curiosidade do meu pai e teve uma ideia
vou fazer um vídeo explicando para o meu
pai como essa tal de Tomorrowland
e editei postei o vídeo e para minha
surpresa instantaneamente o vídeo um
viralizou eu expliquei para o meu pai e
para mais de 25 milhões de pessoas que
foram influenciadas organicamente com
positividade ué Thiago você acabou de me
falar que você tava numa fase triste
difícil sim eu tava mas Então como que
deu certo pelo motivo que na hora que eu
estava fazendo eu me senti a realizado
sabe quando você faz uma coisa com amor
sabe quando você faz com amor e mostrar
o mundo com viés otimista Esse é o meu
propósito é isso que me move por isso
que na hora que eu tava gravando era só
alegria porque eu vou jogando meu corpo
no mundo andando por todos os cantos e
pela lei natural dos encontros eu deixo
e recebo um tanto
E olha que lindo isso eu deixo meus
vídeos de forma positiva e recebo isso
de volta
e dar e receber você colhe o que você
planta já escutou essa frase certeza e é
isso que eu vou fazer aqui no meu
segundo ter Dex eu quero plantar mais
então além do Thiago aqui ó pessoa
jurídica de terno tá eu quero trazer
também o Tiago pessoa física
E é só o Tiago
E aí
Oi e aí se Tiago que que a compartilhar
com você três coisas que são muito
importantes e especiais para perceber um
futuro melhor
é a primeira coisa é sobre a realidade
do mundo eu vejo não converso de era de
gente fina elegante e sincera com
habilidade pra dizer Mais sim do que não
será que a gente convive mais com sim ou
com o não fui procurar essa resposta na
internet tem uma ferramenta que mensura
qual palavra foi mais utilizada aí eu
comparei o sim ou não e eu fiquei
chocado ao perceber o quanto o não bomba
mais que eu sim eu pensei tá eu vejo as
postagens estão lá escrito assim como
não fazer isso mas não tá escrito como
sim fazer isso
bom então por um lado isso faz sentido
mas analisando outras coisas da vida do
dia a dia as notícias dos jornais a
maioria delas com certeza são negativas
Então quer dizer que a gente se
interessa mais por coisas negativas do
que positivas então eu percebi que nós
temos mais não do que sim
é mas eu vou usar o meu tempo aqui para
influenciaram sim é E aí você se
pergunta aí quem que é esse cara que tá
lhe falando quem é esse Thiago na fila
do pão dizendo que vai me influenciar eu
sou um cara corajoso que eu acredito no
poder do sim Então vamos continuar com
as três coisas que o primeiro eu já
falei que é sobre o quanto nós temos
mais coisas negativas do que positivas
nos influenciando
e nós temos entendemos essa realidade
que tem mais não do que sim com essa
informação a gente vai para segunda
coisa que a sobre influenciar e ser
influenciado Será que tem como não ser
influenciado eu vou te explicar isso
através de uma metáfora porque senão
você vai ficar aí pensando que eu vivo
sempre no mundo da lua porque sou
cientista o meu papo é futurista é
lunático eu não sou cientista mas eu vou
ser bem lunático para te explicar aqui
sobre influência Então vamos lá para o
mundo da lua pensa na lua que você
quiser só lua preferida pode ser
minguante cheia crescente nova
e tem gente que corta cabelo de acordo
com essa fase da lua aí é tem gente que
planta de acordo com as fases da lua o
movimento da lua ele influencia na maré
alta e baixa dos oceanos quer dizer a
lua influencia a terra agora vamos
pensar o contrário
e a terra influencia a lua também afinal
a Lua fica ao redor da terra girando
girando Isso me lembra até quando eu era
pequeno que eu ficava ali ó ao redor da
minha mãe o tempo inteiro girando agora
vamos para um lugar mais longe o sol o
sol ele tá mais distante da terra do que
a lua mas o sol também influencia a
terra porque a gente fica ali ao redor
do sol girando e o sol ele é muito
importante para a gente ele invade a
nossa atmosfera e ele traz vida traz
calor faz crescer as plantas
Oi e o tanto que é lindo um dia
ensolarado você poder pegar um bronze na
praia na piscina na laje onde você
quiser só que dependendo do dia da hora
você não pega um bronze né E se não
passar protetor solar você se queima
quem já se queimou no sol Sabe o que eu
tô falando que a gente fica aqui numa
temperatura de 40 Graus 50 graus agora
vamos pensar lá no sol ele tá numa
temperatura de mais de 5 mil graus
Celsius
e o sol influencia a terra Agora imagina
a influência que o sol causa nele mesmo
e agora deixa eu traduzir essa metáfora
da influência dos astros do sistema
solar para a influência do mundo das
nossas cabeças
e quando sai uma informação do mundo da
minha cabeça para o mundo da sua cabeça
eu tenho clecio quando sai uma
informação do mundo da sua cabeça para o
mundo da minha cabeça você me influencia
quando nós conversamos com os nossos
pais amigos pessoas que amamos quem está
ao nosso redor uh cada palavra
influência
Oi e essa segunda coisa nós
influenciamos e somos influenciados
e eu tomo muito cuidado com isso muito
cuidado com isso mesmo quando eu tô
fazendo um vídeo aqui falando para vocês
porque
e o que você transmitir volta com
intensidade quando não souber o que
pedir peça felicidade felicidade dar e
receber felicidade influenciar com
felicidade Esse é um dos segredo dessa
vida maluca que a gente vive e todo
mundo qualquer pessoa pode buscar a
felicidade a felicidade ela não custa
dinheiro
e a felicidade ela custa entender aqui
a entender aqui
é só que nem todo mundo quer entender
aqui porque talvez compreender as coisas
como são faz a gente mudar de opinião eu
prefiro ser essa metamorfose ambulante
do que ter aquela velha opinião formada
sobre tudo e pega essa visão Nós seres
humanos somos de uma espécie de sucesso
em multiplicação Isso é fato nós saímos
em 200 anos de um bilhão de seres E
Agora Nós já somos quase oito milhões é
um Case extraordinário Mas é claro que
essa multiplicação rápida tem as suas
consequências mas eu também percebo que
tem a sua solução
bom e nós vamos alcançar o futuro
desejável quando a gente aprender a
viver dentro da nossa capacidade de
carga mas como assim Thiago Eu vou te
explicar de uma forma bem simples que
mexe no seu bolso para você me entender
imagina que você tem dinheiro investido
esse dinheiro está rendendo juros aí
você vai pega os juros para comprar
alguma coisa para você uma roupa o que
você quiser
e se você pegar só os juros é mais
saudável para suas economias o que se
você pegar parte do dinheiro principal
porque aí uma hora esse dinheiro pode
acabar
Ah e assim é com a natureza se a gente
pegar só o juros é isso isso é
sustentabilidade e a gente tá nessa
transição buscando fazer esses ajustes
no mundo
e eu vejo a vida melhor no futuro Olha
isso que aconteceu aqui agora eu te
contei uma história e fiz uma influência
para você ter uma visão positiva do
Futuro
é legal Pensa bem essa foi uma
influência do mundo da minha cabeça para
o mundo da sua cabeça
é só que foi de dentro para fora mas é
influência mais poderosa que existe é a
de dentro do mundo da nossa cabeça para
dentro de dentro para dentro quando a
gente faz uma mudança no nosso mundo
quando a gente faz um ajuste de
pensamento isso vai reverberar tão forte
dentro da gente e vai continuar e quando
pelo mundo das pessoas que estão ao
nosso redor tudo que nós fazemos
sentimos falamos ou ouvimos vemos tudo
influencia tudo influencia a primeira
coisa entendemos a realidade do mundo
tem mais não sem complexo de Poliana
segunda coisa nós influenciamos somos
influenciados e influenciamos mais ainda
nos mesmos e para explicar a terceira
coisa
e vamos pensar no futuro tem muita coisa
no futuro que dá para a gente ir se
prevenir se preservar se planejar Mas
tem uma coisa que não dá para planejar
que a felicidade não dá para planejar só
dá para viver
e você vai rir sem perceber Felicidade é
só questão de ser eu acredito que com
essas três coisas quando você busca mais
sim para sua vida quando você percebe a
influência que você causa na vida dos
outros e na sua e quando você entende o
que é felicidade para você
E com isso eu acredito que você vai
conseguir enxergar o futuro e o mundo de
forma positiva e quando você tiver no
momento desafiador que você não tiver
conseguindo tá tudo bem faz parte e aí o
que que eu faço vou te responder com a
frase o meu jargão do canal Vamos
começar tudo de novo todos os dias todos
os momentos nós temos uma nova
oportunidade de recomeçar afinal temos
nosso próprio tempo eu não tô aqui
porque eu quero mudar muito
Hoje eu tô aqui para influenciar para
que ele mude
é muito obrigada a